and Democrats threw around a lot of well
prevarication we don't want to say the
word lie because all the people worry
about that hearing today but house Intel
chair Adam Schiff he really sunk to a
new low by closing the hearing with this
the president praises the corrupt he
praises the corrupt lewd Senco he
condemns the just you and then he asks
for an investigation of the Biden's
there is no camouflaging that corrupt
intent we are adjourned mr. speaker I'll
stay carry condition chairman you
disparage disparage those members on
this side of the aisle we should have a
chance to respond to your disparaging
remarks
joining me now is congressman Lee Zeldin
House Foreign Affairs Committee member
was in the hearing room obviously now
congressman we've said all along this
was impeachment by a motion it was a
theatrical production it fell flat got
terrible reviews on day one they knew
they had to try to bring the drama so
it's like begging for applause what was
that moment like why so I was there in
the hearing all day today as I was there
all day Wednesday afterwards by the way
we went back into the bunker in the
Capitol basement we went right back to
the skiff for a deposition that took
place this afternoon into the evening
we're back there in that bunker tomorrow
and tell us about the moment with the
elevation and they were trying they were
milking this for although they filled up
the crowd with all their supporters are
you all not doing that you guys got to
fill it I fill it up as well yeah well
it was there's a lot of effort on the
part of Democrats over the course of the
entire day to make something out of what
was at best a draw for them and the fact
is that there was nothing new to learn I
mean they are a not only did they leak
out the best of what you Voinovich would
have said when she gave her deposition
in the skiff they spun it in a way to
set these higher expectations so it was
actually worse if you're watching at
home over the course of today not only
did you not learn anything new but you
realized the way what the media was
telling you about we ivanovitch was
gonna have to say wasn't actually their
Jovanovic was out of the position she
has no first time but she was upset she
lost her job I mean welcome to the world
I mean and if civil servants don't serve
forever yeah the president can't pick
and pick his ambassador she has a great
job at Georgetown University not a bad
deal choice that's exactly what you
wanted to be able to teach future
Foreign Service officers she got the
position she wanted my backgrounds the
military the Department of Defense can
pick you up and move you that you post
courtesy of the US tax payer regardless
of what the president thinks I want to
play for you Adam Schiff asks you in
Voinovich about the intimidation
campaign watch as we sit here testifying
the president is attacking you on
Twitter I'll read part of one of his
tweets everywhere murray ivanovitch went
turned bad
she started off in Somalia how did that
go he goes on to say later in the tweet
is that US presidents taps the right to
appoint ambassadors the president real
time is attacking you it's very
intimidating Schiff is such a fraud okay
so the president puts out this entire
tweet and Schiff gives his own rendition
of the tweet if you want to ask the
witness for her feelings on the tweet
they've been asking her feelings about
everything else let her read the entire
tweet for herself and then ask her a
question but for example the second
sentence of that tweet which was a
legitimate point that they left out they
cherry picked out during that first 45
minute line that question obviously the
president noticed this the July 25th
call transcript the response from
President Solinsky to President Trump as
you were just getting into in the last
segment president Solinsky calls
ambassador Jovanovic a bad ambassador
president szalinski says that he
believes that ambassador Jovanovic had
loyalty to president poroshenko so why
don't you just allow ambassador
Jovanovic to answer that question
importantly if he's worried that it's
intimidating why is he reading okay so
obviously he's intelligent witness
Jovanovic had no idea exactly he loves
the leading questions you've onerous had
no idea that this sweetie had even
existed do my witness gagging not
allowing us several Republican witnesses
or witness coaching as we saw with
lieutenant colonel of Inman man Adam
Schiff needs to look in the mirror he's
he's a cute he does everything accuses
others of you what did he feel about the
the way he's treated Stefanik oh gosh I
mean he does not like Elise Stefanik
and Elise Stefanik has been a strong
woman she does her home right again
she's been working hard she's preparing
for all these all these all this
testimony she's been fantastic and Adam
Schiff hates that Marx and you're gonna
hear anything from him tomorrow OMB
official who's going to testify or give
a deposition even though the White House
says no he's expected to to come and he
would be answering questions with
regards to the hold on aid but keep him
on Ukraine did not know about the whole
done aid until the end of August the aid
gets released shortly thereafter and
guess what Ukraine had to do in order to
get that aid release not absolutely
nothing
congressman thanks for stopping by you
had a long day my friend back to the
dungeon for you tomorrow and up next
Tammy Bruce